quand le gouvernement va-t-il mettre fin
au déficit inflationniste nous
sommes on va intervenir à la Cour
suprême dans le cas de la loi 21 la
poutine
[Applaudissements]
c'est sûr que gros changement égal
grosse résistance mais il faut pas se
laisser arrêter par ça c'est beau le
projet de loi mais les Québécois aux
autres qui veulent c'est chirurgie puis
veulent arrêter d'attendre
[Musique]
alors pendant qu'on commence à planifier
l'été les politiciens pensent déjà à ce
qui les attend cet automne gouvernement
fédéral aura-t-il finalement tourné la
page sur la question de la gérance
étrangère ou en seront les réformes
initiées à Québec quelques-unes avec ce
thème là qu'on va lancer cette portion
de la conversation commençant par les
dossiers chauds à surveiller à Ottawa
Michel je commence avec les finances
publiques parce que
sans avoir un plan de retour pas de
retour complet avec les budgétaire un
moment de contrôle des finances on peut
avoir des surprises la France cette
semaine a failli être décoter c'est pas
rien en Europe la France
d'agences de crédit est obligé donc de
payer beaucoup plus cher pour ces
emprunts on est sur cette voie là s'il
n'y a pas de chemin de réduction
potassium mais de réduction du déficit
il va falloir que le gouvernement s'en
occupe et ils ne l'ont pas fait cette
année Alec deux batailles à surveiller
l'une entre le gouvernement les
plateformes numériques les Facebook et
Google
d'ici la journée qui sont les deux les
deux projets de loi que n'aiment pas que
n'aime pas les géants du web parce que
pour l'instant les signaux à Ottawa sont
allés faire qu'on va mener la bataille
qu'on se laissera pas intimider on verra
si concrètement lorsqu'il est Canadiens
vont perdre d'accès à certaines de leurs
nouvelles via ces plateformes là on va
se comporter différemment il y a un
précédent en Australie qui pouvait être
intéressant de voir à quel point ici ça
va s'appliquer et l'autre bataille je
pense que ça va être sur le
plateformement des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre entre donc tawa et
l'Alberta maintenant Smith et bel et
bien en sel et qu'elle veut comme tous
les premiers ministres albertin depuis
longtemps se battre avec Ottawa sur
cette question là mais si Steven gilbaud
veut avoir la moindre chance de de
commencer à infléchir les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre du Canada et garder
la crédibilité qui lui reste communiste
d'environnement il faut qu'il plafonne
ses émissions-là
j'ai hâte de voir comment on va réussir
à faire ça ça va être une conversation
parce que même tu es pas sur la même
longueur d'onde
avant de vous parler de l'automne je
pense que tout le monde a les yeux
braquer sur les élections partielles du
19 juin et pourquoi parce que un il y a
cette affrontement entre Maxime Bernier
et un candidat de conservateur dans la
circonscription manitobaine de portage
Liska si vous regardez là vous vous
laissez distraire parce que la vraie
affaire c'est dans Winnipeg Sud pourquoi
parce que c'est une circonscription
libérale que Steven Harper a gagné quand
tu as gagné un gouvernement majoritaire
et si Monsieur Poirier qui est faible au
Québec veut devenir Premier ministre il
faut toujours bien qu'il commence à
gagner
et
le score libéral va être important là et
aussi dans Oxford en Ontario même si
c'est un siège sûr conservateur je vous
invite pas nécessairement à passer
beaucoup de temps dans le suspense de
Westman
c'est intéressant parce que le côté
présente mais c'est quand même un
château fort céréales ce serait vraiment
étonnant qui se passe autre chose mais
entendons-nous on peut surveiller plein
de dossiers à l'automne en réservoir la
vérité c'est qu'on est en période pré
électorale et que ce qui va se passer là
c'est prendre un peu le poux de
l'électorat après un six mois difficile
pour le gouvernement et après les
premiers mois de Monsieur poignet comme
chef
effectivement parce que ça va donner le
temps ça commence à placer les cartes ça
mobilise les troupes aussi un peu ça
énergise des troupes alors intéressant
de voir tout ça donc c'est chaud à
surveiller à Québec j'ai commencé avec
vous allez qu'est-ce qu'on surveille à
Québec cet auteur plusieurs dossiers les
fameuses consultations sur l'immigration
les seuils c'est cet automne en
septembre que ça va avoir lieu il faut
que un moment donné la réforme du B
commence à s'appliquer là le fameux gros
projet de loi de Christian Dubé voilà
l'adopter cet automne il doit l'adopter
cet automne puis pour terminer peut-être
les négociations avec le secteur public
en disant que la table mal été mise avec
la hausse de salade des députés mais là
la fonction publique québécoise dit nous
là l'entendre que tu es conclu entre
Ottawa et donc le gouvernement fédéral
il est syndicats secteurs publics c'est
pas suffisant c'est quand même 13 % qui
ont obtenu 12,6 %. nous aussi c'est ça
on part en grève le gouvernement offre
9%. alors l'écart il est énorme à la
table de négociation largeur de voir le
climat à l'automne entre le gouvernement
le GO et le secteur public
Chantal qu'est-ce qu'on soit au Québec
parce que je vais changer ma réponse
normalement mais toutes vos réponses
allez-y la Cour d'appel du Québec a
entendu le contestation de la loi 21 sur
la laïcité l'automne dernier à un moment
donné ça va prendre 9 mois de gestation
ça commence à faire on accouche d'une
décision cette décision quelle qu'elle
soit vos pavé la voix à un appel en
cours suprême oui et donc une reprise du
débat sur la classe de dérogation et son
utilisation préventive sur la loi sur la
laïcité on se prépare une année
juridique assez intéressante en plus des
contestations de la nouvelle mouture
d'achat de la langue française qui
commence à s'enclencher donc oui à
surveiller l'automne prochain
le gouvernement juste un Trudeau a déjà
dit qu'il allait s'en mêler en cours
suprême et Monsieur poirievre dit moi
aussi j'imagine que c'est
des positions qui intéressent le Bloc
québécois qui va pouvoir dire nous on
est les seuls qui défendent les lois du
Québec et d'autres parts de débat au
sens large sur la clause de dérogation
c'est quand même un débat qui intéresse
à peu près tout le monde au Canada
Premier ministre provinciaux comme le
gouvernement fédéral c'est une grosse
cause dans tous les cas et on sait pas
ce qui a cours d'appel va dire mais on
sait que ça va enclencher ce processus
là ça va aller en appel à construire de
façon d'une autre quel que soit la
décision ça va se rendre là
auquel vous pouvez vous attendre
d'ailleurs
on en a beaucoup parlé moins un peu mais
ça va revenir ça vaut l'appeler ça
serait intéressant de voir si la Cour
suprême se penche là-dessus comment on
se penche là dessus Michel qu'est-ce
qu'on surveille à Québec les réformes
parallèles de la santé et de l'éducation
si vous regardez les deux projets de loi
et ça ressemble énormément c'est une
façon de concentrer des pouvoirs entre
les mains du ministre sous le prétexte
de la décentralisation toujours mais
quand même ça fera pas ça et
d'augmentation des services
d'augmentation de la de la qualité de
l'éducation or est-ce que on peut
convaincre le public puisque qu'on peut
convaincre le milieu de la santé de
l'éducation que des réformes qui sont
essentiellement administratives vont
donner des résultats d'un salle de
classe de la salle d'opération ça c'est
pas sûr
intéressant à surveiller donc cet
automne en attendant évidemment les
vacances d'été qui s'enviennent au
Québec les travaux sont terminés à
Ottawa ça s'en vient incessamment et là
on pense aux vacances on pense à des
idées de vacances des endroits peut-être
une petite lecture aussi pendant qu'on
est sur la plage ou au camping
suggestion de mes trois collaborateurs
dans un instant
[Musique]